i wanna thank you for something very
important as well
those
three four thousand interactions this
weekend one by one
hearing your stories
listening
to the nice words he had to share
to me
about our journeys together
really did something for me this weekend
i'm i'm a pretty motivated monster but
i'm going to tell you right now what you
gave me this weekend instilled in me has
motivated me so much more to continue to
fight for this binary conversation that
i have in my mind
which is
the world is confused
that kindness is the answer
there be no confusion to this community
my intent for all of you
is always and forever going to be
phenomenal because i'm unbelievably
capable of being happy and achieving
what i want
not at your expense
but with you coming along for this
[ __ ] ride
[Applause]
i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
[Music]
don't know about real fears
you're too weak
you're too [ __ ] weak
[Music]
the ones
[Applause]
he's a dude in the black shirt
but now i say yeah
[Applause]
they're a bunch of individuals
[Music]
the blockchain is here
everything that exists right now in nft
form can be wiped out tomorrow and it's
all it's going to it's all going to
happen
it's community thriving 100
everything
everything is but where it gets
interesting
where i'm really intellectually
challenged and fascinated
is for example daos when daos hit the
scene last year like loud
i said to aj said
i don't know about this it's beautiful
on paper but it's not in real life
the community should make all the
decisions i'm like do you understand
two co-ceos is a problem yes if i own a
board ate
the
or a world of women or any creative
commons
somebody's gonna build louis vuitton but
somebody's gonna build walmart
yeah and it's gonna be very fascinating
to see that and i don't think it's wrong
by the way the only reason i'm keeping
the vpns thing the only reason is
because i've always wanted to do it
it's not like that i think it's a better
business or that it's right
it's that i just want to develop
accountable and i don't want you to
you know i just want to have it for fun
but um
it's going to be an amazing decade i'm
incredibly interested
to put in the time and and we'll get
that
[Music]
good morning v-con we are back at it
once again and we're down here on the
floor there's stuff going on all over
the stadium already but we're down here
on the floor where people are lined up
for the selfie station
of course one of the most sought after
places in the stadium is in this line
right now and you guys filed in and ran
down here skipping the pancake breakfast
which is bold but that's going on in the
players lounge as well but if you'd like
a selfie with gary head down to the
floor right now hop in line everyone is
a gary fan and everyone wants a selfie
with him it just goes to show the energy
in this building and it is positive it
is supportive and we're keeping that
going for day three so stay tuned and
keep it up we're gonna be here all day
let's go
good morning
good morning over there
this this this message is especially for
this crew right here i'm gonna go as
fast as i can i'm petrified that is the
word i'm using to let you guys down that
are in line i'm going to go as fast as
humanly possible i'm going to milk it to
the last possible second i'm going to
ask everybody like work with me on this
because i really don't want to let them
down and make them stand for an hour and
not and then have a cut off thank you
cooperate with me i love you
just one simple question this is for
everybody in the building right now
how's recon
i love you
thank you so much
[Music]
this [ __ ] song makes me happy i just
wanted to say thank you so much for
empowering women to be in the space it's
really really encouraging thanks for
seeing it no of course it's like unreal
that's what happens when your mom you do
my trip too what happens when your mom's
your hero oh
thank you oh
i [ __ ] made it will you sign this
real quick
i appreciate you man
appreciate you very much
trash talk episode one changed my life
changed my [ __ ] life so thank you so
much enjoyed your time it's been amazing
everything that we wanted it to be thank
you
you're welcome
you're really inspiring you're very
sweet so nice to meet you um i was
wondering if there's anything that you
could do
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you very much thanks gary had a
good beacon
hey brother
you didn't know who you were before it
came here
[Music]
i'm a new guy to nft what would you uh
what would you tell me about read
everything get educated before you do
anything okay get real educated
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much for everything you do
man my wife is gonna freak thank you
so what's up thank you man come next
year
thank you for everything you're doing
thank you it's incredible because it's
changing like truly so many lives
we're working on i'm a part of the
alopecia community i lost all my hair
when i was 15 and i'm creating a project
because of you i love that
can you please email me about it when
it's ready
please email me about that when it's
ready you promised
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for everything you're doing
thank you
all
i really like
what do you think of the museum
thank you a lot gary thank you so much
for doing your thing
absolutely
how's it going
thank you
suffolk
you like that one
[Music]
you know i was a world class artist you
know what happened man you know what you
know why this happened right
um because you guys thought that aj was
a
better was a better artist
right
i overheard
smart person on earth
one of the few things i was looking
forward to it was finally we just hadn't
been able to chop it up as much as i
wanted to i did you were unbelievable
thank you i love your [ __ ] a lot
i love you so glad you're here what's up
bro let's go
this is gonna be unbelievable i'm ready
20
i'm literally going to make i want to
win a grammy through b friends
badly all right everybody please welcome
to the stage
creator of v friends
gary vaynerchuk
and joining gary on stage
is
sloth
danny cole
isaac drifter wright
and jen stark
i just want to tell you
how grateful i am obviously i've been
putting out a ton of energy uh these
last couple of days but
the
the way that you're all treating each
other and the relationships that are
being built you know several days ago
i threw out a couple things as a
mentality and a framework and a concept
of how we could roll this weekend and
the v friends have absolutely over
delivered and i just want to thank you
for that i would love every person in
this stadium to clap it up for each
other
one thing that made me fall in love with
jen
even more was rv friends collaboration
my favorite part is if you look at our
collaborations i've been excited about
the goat collaborating in the content
and andy's like jen doesn't want to put
the goat in the art and i said good for
her
it's a really fun call out and i want
people to hear this to me that wasn't a
bad thing
full transparency i'm disappointed i'd
like the goat to be like that's you know
but i but i love that you're like no
listen this is what i do and and then it
was and this is back to entitlement then
it was in my court then i was sitting
with it i'm like okay
do you know do i wanna
call jen and be like hey i need to go
and if not that's okay we can do
something else and i really sat on it
and to be frank i just wanted her to be
part of this project and i was like fine
good for you and yes and i think people
have to think about that in creative
processes there's no rules there's just
communication and we must respect other
people's convictions
yeah thank you let's hear it for the
goats and future goats
[Applause]
of
course i think i want you guys to win
calling me out on stage no no no i'm you
know i was giving you roses i love that
you can inspire some people with that a
lot of people think that they need to
say yes
to [ __ ] i was like so pumped like i
respect that so much i really do thank
you
[Music]
see you again great to see you guys
so my dude how are you real pleasure
i've seen this whole process it's so
cool
you know the problem is you got too much
ambition in that beautiful body
now when you you know you listen you've
been through several of them you know
exactly what it is there's moments and
you're gonna either squeeze the [ __ ] out
of that moment or you're not because
they have been flow you've been through
it so
a hundred percent at this point of your
career you know exactly what it is so
you're going to [ __ ] it i'm gonna
squeeze the [ __ ] out of it right now
while i got it
that's what you're gonna learn you're
gonna it's about patterns you know
there's moments like the first time you
have it you're just a kid you don't even
realize web one for me obviously the the
drab like you just like you don't even
realize like you kind of know you know
it's a moment but when you see it the
second time the third time you know
exactly what it is
this is my dad sasha
feed for greatness right here
d.o.g
hey
baby
we've been talking about this [ __ ] for a
long time and we've been on this for
months secretly working it out with
garyvee they didn't think i was gonna
show up goddamn it i'm here
d.o.w
be friends
give a humongous vicon welcome
please
to the legend snoop dogg his son cordell
and his partner nick
[Music]
louder
something i've been very hot on is the
concept of giving people roses while
they're alive
and i just think it's a thing that we
should be doing more for each other
so
given where you're at
this just might be nice for some people
either we all know or maybe some people
we don't even know
if if i just asked you hey give two or
three roses
a person or two or three that
got you to this moment or
maybe was a creative inspiration going
off the last question
what pops to mine who i would definitely
say my wife
definitely would say her
i would give
my son cordell
some flowers too big champ champ champ
yeah cause i got scared because champ
was a football player and champ
was living my dream as a football player
yeah and then champ decided to pull back
and live his dream and as a father i had
to respect that and i had to get behind
him and support him
can we stay on that this is a lot of the
content i put out about parenting and
like i i'm passionate about
letting your kids be them not who you
want them to be from the champ
perspective
there was no confusion we all knew that
that's what was happening that means you
were dealing with that [ __ ] 24 7 365 for
the youngsters in this room and there's
a lot of them
i've been taking selfies a lot the last
three days
there's a lot of
especially immigrant families
like that have a situation where they
love their parents so much that they
want to do what their parents want to do
but i keep telling them eat the pain now
because the resentment that you're gonna
have on your parents forever is gonna be
way worse how did you have the strength
knowing how much you love your dad and
knowing how much anyone was into that
like where where did that come from what
were those conversations with yourself
that got you to the place where you were
ready to make what i believe is one of
the hardest decisions
a child can ever make because when you
love your parent
and you know what they're hoping for you
being able to have the strength to be
your own man or woman to do what you
need to do for you
is a challenging thing at a young age
i mean it was it was extremely difficult
um but
you know you got to just have the
mindset to just keep going and you can't
look at your parents as perfect you know
they had you you know
they wasn't perfect they didn't have
everything figured out and you know
my pops wanted to
you know live his dreams through me i
can't you know fought him for that
because you know if i had a son or
something like that i would have did the
same thing if i didn't know as much as i
knew now you know so
i just look at it as you know we are
human and
i really just bet it on myself you know
i'm a i'm a firm believer in betting on
yourself and
you know i jumped out on a leap of faith
and i landed in the metaverse
i think we're gonna
wrap up here with um
something that we've been in the lab
with for a while late summer early fall
we're going to drop something we're
still cooking
but we want to reward the [ __ ] out of
somebody who owns a vcon nft
it's going to be extremely thoughtful
we're talking access
not just art we're thinking thoughtfully
and the snoop
v friends collab is happening
yes sir
d.o.w.g friends is going to double gv
is going down
let's hear it for these three get real
[ __ ] loud
nothing on earth can ever be a hundred
percent but thank you for the 95 96 94
of
civility kindness we got a little
excited about running after the merch
that's on me i'll fix that next time and
we'll figure out some of the line
situation for next year but i'll double
down on standing in that selfie line to
have those moments that i have with all
of you
who the [ __ ] coming back next year
thank you for everything that was a very
very very impactful weekend for us
really what thank you
love you guys
really proud of you
i love
i hope it impacted you in the way that i
hope it did
it's a very different thing it's very
[ __ ] real
and
for the little amount of time that i
actually put
into actually pulling this off
because it's staggeringly low
it has to do with so much more with the
zacks and you know and andy's and maha's
and all of you may
running in perfect timing
just all of you you know i just can't
thank you enough i know what happens
when you put in kindness i'm only a
byproduct of my mom putting kindness
into me that's who i am and so
i just knew this would work
because i knew that all our missteps
would be absorbed by all the work and
love that we put out
that
has nothing to do with the fact that
every person on this stage put in so
much
and tried so hard and i just thank you
so much for being a part of this thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]